well I think probably that leaders could
do we most help the world will be to say
what they mean in other words to say
that they're going to do something and
do it or so they're not going to do
something and not going that goes
politicians as well as businessmen
because it's important that everyone
should communicate very clearly on the
other hand I think those who don't
regard themselves as leaders need to
take more power into their own hands not
in the sense of nagging the politicians
and the rich of this world to do things
on their behalf but actually to give
them themselves politicians are very
funny people they don't they tend to
believe that what they say is what
happens and of course the two are very
different so I think they're unbalanced
they should say what they mean and the
rest of us should do what we think we
ought to do rather than wait for our
leaders to do a chorus